es un paisaje familiar en el horizonte
del sur de israel un aluvión de juguetes
provenientes de casa la mayoría de ellos
interceptados antes de que toque el
suelo desarrollado por empresas
israelíes con el apoyo de los eeuu la
cúpula de hierro está diseñada
específicamente para derribar cohetes de
corto alcance como los que son lanzados
desde casa un aluvión de cohetes
provenientes de casa la mayoría de ellos
interceptados antes de que toque el
suelo
usando radares y software de análisis
sólo interceptan misiles que representan
una amenaza aunque no es barato cada
interceptación cuesta hasta 150 mil
dólares el sistema presume una tasa de
éxito del 90 por ciento en 11 días de
lucha entre israel y hamas en mayo de
2021 se dispararon más de 4.000 cohetes
hacia israel desde gaza
la mayoría fueron interceptados por los
que no lo fueron dejaron 10 israelíes
muertos y más de 700 heridos
israel está buscando expandir y
diversificar sus capacidades de defensa
asignando 250 millones de dólares para
desarrollar un nuevo sistema conocido
como la radio de hierro la cúpula usa
tecnología láser para eliminar objetivos
aéreos que son demasiado pequeños para
que la cúpula de hierro se active y este
sistema resultaría mucho más económico
sistemas innovadores de antimisiles como
la cúpula de hierro han traído garantías
y también la vida para muchos en el sur
de israel y han aliviado la presión
sobre las tropas